PRESIDENT BIDEN IS WAKING UP IN
MEXICO FACING SOME CRITICISM
INCLUDING FROM MEMBERS OF HIS
OWN PARTY AFTER HIS FIRST VISIT
TO THE BORDER SINCE TAKING
OFFICE.
IT WAS A CONTROLLED VISIT TO EL
PASO, TEXAS, IT INCLUDED
MEETINGS WITH LOCAL PORD BORDER
PATROL AGENTS AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS, BUT PRESIDENT BIDEN
DID NOT SEE ANY MIGRANTS THERE,
INCLUDING VISITING AN AID
CENTER, THERE WERE NO MIGRANTS
THERE AT THE TIME, THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYING IT WAS A
COINCIDENCE.
BUT OUR REPORTING SHOWING THERE
WERE AND ARE HUNDREDS OF
MIGRANTS ON THE STREETS OF EL
PASO, INCLUDING CHILDREN.
ROSA FLORES JOINS US LIVE FROM
EL PASO THIS MORNING.
AND THAT'S YOUR REPORTING, THE
MIGRANTS WERE THERE, THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T INTERACT WITH
ANY OF THEM?
>> Reporter: NO, HE DID NOT.
THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
BEING CRITICIZED BY BOTH SIDES
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE DIDN'T SEE.
SO LET ME SHOW YOU.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MIGRANT CAMPS
HERE IN DOWNTOWN EL PASO.
YOU KNOW, THE IMMIGRATION
ADVOCATES HERE IN EL PASO AND
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT USUALLY
DON'T AGREE ON MUCH BUT THEY DO
RAISE THE SAME QUESTION.
IF PRESIDENT BIDEN CAME HERE TO
EL PASO TO SEE THE REALITY ON
THE GROUND ABOUT THE BORDER AND
DIDN'T COME HERE, WHAT'S
CONSIDERED THE EPICENTER OF THIS
CRISIS, DID HE LEAVE WITH A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING?
SHE WANTS TO BE A TEACHER.
THESE SISTERS HAVE BEEN LIVING
IN THIS MAKESHIFT MIGRANT CAMP
OUTSIDE AN EL PASO CHURCH FOR A
WEEK.
SHE WANTS TO BE REPUNZAL.
PLAYING WITH TOYS IS A LUXURY
THEY HAVEN'T ENJOYED SINCE
LEAVING VENEZUELA FOUR MONTHS
AGO, ACCORDING TO THEIR DAD.
HE SAID HE DECIDED TO COME TO
THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION IN VENEZUELA
BECAUSE THERE'S NO EDUCATION
REALLY FOR HIS DAUGHTERS.
THEY ARE AMONG THE HUNDREDS OF
MIGRANTS WHO CALL THE STREETS OF
EL PASO HOME.
ARGUABLY THE EPICENTER OF THE
CURRENT BORDER CRISIS.
A SCENE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
SKIPPED DURING HIS FIRST VISIT
TO THE BORDER.
A SHORT 3-HOUR STOP IN EL PASO
THAT PROMPTED CRITICISM BY THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS.
>> THIS IS NOTHING BUT FOR SHOW.
>> Reporter: AND PROTESTS BY
LOCAL IMMIGRATION AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
LIKE FERNANDO GARCIA.
>> YOU THINK THIS IS A PHOTO OP
FOR THE PRESIDENT?
>> IN THREE HOURS WHAT CAN YOU
DO WITH THAT?
>> Reporter: OUTRAGE OVER
POLICIES LIKE THE TRUMP ERA
PANDEMIC PUBLIC HEALTH RULE
KNOWN AS TITLE 42 SAYS GARCIA.
THAT RULE ALLOWS BORDER AGENTS
TO SWIFTLY EXPEL MIGRANTS TO
MEXICO.
BIDEN SAID THIS ABOUT THE
POLICY.
I DON'T LIKE TITLE 42.
>> Reporter: JUST DAYS AGO HE
EXPANDED TO CUBANS, HAITIANS,
VENEZUELANS AND NICARAGUANS.
DURING HIS VISIT, BIDEN STOPPED
BY A PORT OF ENTRY, A MIGRANT
RESPITE CENTER AND BY THE BORDER
WALL BUT DIDN'T APPEAR TO SEE OR
MEET ANY MIGRANTS, WHICH GARCIA
SAYS THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT
EXPOSED TO THE FULL MAGNITUDE OF
THE IMMIGRATION CRISIS.
>> THREE HOURS.
>> Reporter: IS THAT ENOUGH?
>> NO.
OBVIOUSLY NOT ENOUGH.
>> Reporter: THE TIMING OF THE
PRESIDENT'S VISIT IS ALSO
RAISING EYEBROWS BECAUSE THE
SITUATION HERE AS IMPROVED.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE IN
MID DECEMBER WHEN HUNDREDS OF
MIGRANTS WERE LINING UP IN
FREEZING TEMPERATURES WAITING TO
TURN THEMSELVES IN TO
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES.
AT THE TIME BORDER PATROL SAID
THEY WERE ENCOUNTERING ABOUT
2,500 MIGRANTS PER DAY.
NOW LOOK, THE LINES ARE GONE AND
THE SYMBOL OF DETERRENCE IS THE
TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD AND THE
FENCING THEY PUT UP, ACCORDING
TO DHS, THE NUMBER OF MIGRANT
ENCOUNTERS HAS DECREASED TO 700
PER DAY.
THE SISTERS' FAVORITE TOY, A
TABLET TO LEARN NUMBERS AND THE
ENGLISH ALPHABET.
THEIR DREAM, LEARNING TO SPEAK
ENGLISH.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL THE
PRESIDENT?
>> HE SAYS HIS MESSAGE TO THE
PRESIDENT IS THAT NOT ALL
MIGRANTS ARE BAD.
MOST OF THE MIGRANTS ARE LIKE
HIM, HE'S A FATHER, HE'S HERE
WITH HIS CHILDREN AND THEY'RE
JUST HERE FOR A BETTER LIFE.
>> Reporter: NOW THEY'RE
SLEEPING INSIDE THE SHELTER HERE
AT THE CHURCH, THEY'RE ALLOWED
TO.
SOME OF THE FAMILIES ARE NOW.
BACK TO PRESIDENT BIDEN, MY
COLLEAGUE MJ LEE ASKED THE WHITE
HOUSE ABOUT THE PRESIDENT NOT
INTERACTING OR MEETING WITH ANY
MIGRANTS AND A SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL TOLD HER
THERE WERE NO MIGRANTS AT THE
RESPITE CENTER AT THE TIME THE
PRESIDENT VISITED, AND IT WAS
COINCIDENTAL.
BUT I CHECKED THE DASH BOARD THE
CITY OF EL PASO HAS.
AND AT THE TIME THE PRESIDENT
WAS HERE, THERE WERE REALLY
1,000 MIGRANTS IN FEDERAL
DETENTION SO IF THE PRESIDENT
WANTED TO SEE CONDITIONS, I
DOUBT THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WOULD HAVE BEEN
DENIED ACCESS.
>> IT'S REMARKABLE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING BEHIND YOU.
THOSE ARE MIGRANTS SLEEPING ON
THE STREET OF EL PASO.
RIGHT?
>> Reporter: YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WE'VE SEEN THIS FOR WEEKS.
IF THE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE
STOPPED BY HERE, HE WOULD HAVE
SEEN THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE.
YOU SEE THEM HERE BEHIND ME.
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
STREETS OF AMERICA, I SHOULD
HIGHLIGHT.
THIS IS A CITY IN AMERICA, IN
THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE TOP EXECUTIVE OF THIS
COUNTRY CAME HERE, HE DID NOT
COME TO SEE THIS.
>> WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE THERE AND
CONTINUE TO BE THERE TO SHOW IT
TO US.
THANK YOU FOR THE REPORTING
PHIL MATTINGLY, I POSE THE SAME
QUESTION IN THE SENSE THAT IN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WILL DELIVER
HIS STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
HE'LL BE IN THE CHAMBER WITH THE
REPUBLICAN SPEAKER BEHIND HIM.
REPUBLICANS SAY THIS WAS A PHOTO
OP.
THE REPUBLICANS AND THEIR
SUPPORT IN THEIR MEDIA NETWORK
HAVE SAID WHY HASN'T HE BEEN TO
THE BORDER BEFORE, WHY IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT?
DO THEY SAY, WE'LL GIVE YOU
SECURITY MONEY, NOT THE WALL,
TECHNOLOGY, BUT IN EXCHANGE GIVE
THE DREAMERS CITIZENSHIP?
CREATE A GUEST WORKER PROGRAM
THAT A LOT OF KEVIN McCARTHY'S
CONSTITUENTS BACK HOME IN
BAKERSFIELD WOULD LIKE.
DO THEY SEE AN EFFORT TO
PRESSURE THE REPUBLICANS OR WANT
HANDS OFF?
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THE
EL PASO VISIT, WITHIN THIS
CONTEXT, IS YES, THEY DO.
WHEN YOU TALK TO ADVISERS, THEY
SEE THIS AS A DIVIDED GOVERNMENT
AS OFTEN THE TIME WHEN YOU CAN
MAKE DEALS ON THE MOST
COMPLICATED AND POLITICALLY
TOXIC ISSUES.
CERTAINLY HOUSE REPUBLICANS WILL
HAVE A SAY IN THAT.
BUT THEY FEEL LIKE THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO AT LEAST RAISE AN
ISSUE THAT FOR THE TWO YEARS
THEY CONTROLLED ALL OF
GOVERNMENT, NEVER REALLY GOT OFF
THE SHELF IN ANY WAY, SHAPE, OR
FORM.
IN PART BECAUSE THIS ISN'T JUST
A DEMOCRATS VERSUS REPUBLICAN
ISSUES.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES
WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
WHEN IT COMES TO IMMIGRATION.
HOWEVER -- SO I THINK YOU WILL
SEE THE PRESIDENT NOT ONLY IN
THE STATE OF THE UNION BUT ALSO
WHENEVER HE GIVES REMARKS IN
MEXICO WILL TALK ABOUT
BIPARTISAN IMMIGRATION REFORM,
WILL TALK ABOUT TRYING TO FIND
SOME SEMBLANCE OF A FRAMEWORK
THAT THEY CAN START PUTTING
TOGETHER.
AND IF THEY DON'T TRY AND PUT
THIS VERY MUCH IN THE LAP OF
REPUBLICANS AS BEING THE
OBSTRUCTIONISTS WHO GOT IN THE
WAY OF ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN A VULNERABLE ISSUE
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
POLITICALLY OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
I DO THINK, HOWEVER, THAT WHEN
YOU TALK TO OFFICIALS WHO LOOK
AT THIS ISSUE AND TRY AND FIGURE
OUT WHERE THINGS ARE GOING FROM
HERE ON OUT, IT IS A VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE, THAT'S NOT
CHANGING.
I THINK THE PATHWAY NOW IS STILL
--
>> IT'S A COMPLICATED ISSUE AND
NOT CHANGING IN PART BECAUSE YOU
CAN GO BACK TO -- I COVERED THE
CLINTON WHITE HOUSE AND THE
GEORGE W. BUSH WHITE HOUSE WHEN
THIS WAS FRONT AND CENTER.
AND THE -- IT'S A COMPLICATED
ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN PART OF
THE DYSFUNCTION OF WASHINGTON
FOR SO LONG.
THERE WERE PICTURES OF THE
PRESIDENT WHEN HE GOT TO TEXAS.
THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR MET HIM.
AND THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
HANDED THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES A LETTER IN WHICH
HE SAID YOU SHOULD DETAIN
EVERYBODY WHO ILLEGALLY CROSSES
THE BORDER, YOU SHOULD FULLY
ENFORCE THAT TITLE 42 WHICH IS
TURN THEM BACK, PSYCHING STYLE,
LET THEM FILE -- ASYLUM, LET
THEM FILE INJURIES WHERE.
NAME MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS AS
FOREIGN TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS WAS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
CONSTANT CRITIC OF THE PRESIDENT
TO POLYLIGHTLY AND RESPECTFULLY
SAY THIS IS WHAT I WANT YOU TO
DO, SIR.
IS THERE ANY CHANCE, MAYBE NOT
WITH THE CONGRESS, THE
GOVERNORS, IS THERE ANY CHANCE
OR ARE WE IN THIS POLITICAL
STANDOFF?
>> I THINK WE'RE THIS A
POLITICAL STANDOFF.
I THINK THERE IS A REASON, AS
YOU SAID, THIS HAS NOT GOTTEN
DONE.
PEOPLE ARE DUG IN ON ALL SIDES.
AND IT'S SOMETHING WHERE
ANYTHING -- ANY TYPE OF MOVEMENT
ON IT COULD BE CONSIDERED
AMNESTY.
REPUBLICANS WILL NOT DO THAT.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF DEBATES WITHIN
THE LEFT ON HOW TO HANDLE THIS,
AND PEOPLE WILL POINT OUT THAT
IT IS NOT ILLEGAL TO CROSS THE
BORDER AND IS ON SEEK ASYLUM.
THAT IS NOT ILLEGAL.
SO HOW YOU DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE,
IT DOES TAKE A CONGRESS AND
LAWMAKERS AND POLICY PEOPLE WHO
ARE WILLING TO WORK TOGETHER.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT FOR THE
PAST FEW DECADES.
>> AND BACK TO THE PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION QUICKLY, BOTH OF
YOU JUMP IN, IF YOU'RE KEVIN
McCARTHY AS SPEAKER AND IF -- IF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS THE LEADER OF THE
COUNTRY, IF HE MADE A PROPOSAL,
IS THERE ANY CHANCE THIS
REPUBLICAN SPEAKER AND THE
TENUOUS GROUND HE LIVES ON COULD
TRY TO NEGOTIATE?
>> ANY SORT OF PROPOSAL FROM THE
DEMOCRATS IS GOING TO INCLUDE
SOMETHING LIKE YOU SAID
DREAMERS, AND THAT IS NOT WHERE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY STAND RIGHT
NOW.
THEY WANT BORDER SECURITY FIRST,
AND THEN MAYBE THEY'LL DISCUSS
DREAMERS, ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
LEGAL IMMIGRATION, BUT THEY ARE
NOT CLOSE TO THAT.
>> WE SHOULD POINT OUT HOW TOXIC
IT IS ABOUT TO BE ON CAPITOL
HILL IN TERMS OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS, POTENTIAL
IMPEACHMENT OF ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS.
SO WHILE THEORETICALLY I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH PHIL THAT
IT COULD HAPPEN, I ALSO THINK
THAT THE POLITICS ARE GOING TO
GET INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT FOR
BOTH SIDES.